in this video I'm gonna be sharing some
of my favorite fitness muscle building
and training books if you read each of
these you'll come away with a far more
comprehensive knowledge when it comes to
your training as compared with 99% of
people who work out regularly these are
my top fitness books and I believe they
represent all you need for a badass
fitness knowledge the fitness
instructors handbook by Mark Coulson I'm
currently studying for a level 3 fitness
instructors diploma and so I have to go
back to basics and pick up this book
it's endorsed by a reps meaning that it
follows the syllabus that UK trainers
need to know some of the information in
here is a bit basic and some parts are
even outdated but has a comprehensive
introduction to the basics of anatomy
program writing hypertrophy fitness is a
great place to start I imagine that the
u.s. equivalents would likewise be as
helpful regardless of whether you're
planning on doing a training course a
book like this is a good one to start
with and it's my deal foundation to then
build off of with the other books on
this list overcoming gravity by Stephen
lay this is D guide to calisthenics and
bodyweight training
Bar None it goes extremely in-depth and
is absolutely massive it will help you
to progress to avoid injury and to train
in a way that's smarter and anatomically
sound if you want to get the plant or if
you want to get handstand presses this
book will help you get there I will say
though that some background in fitness
and some foundational knowledge will
help you out here as it's not the most
welcoming for beginners and there are
very few pictures and its massive which
is all awesome but it can be a bit
intimidating when you first thump it
onto the table these moves are complex
and challenging and they force you to
utilize all the concepts and
understanding you have about fitness
actually think that in learning about
plants alone you can gain a far greater
appreciation of your body and strength
as a whole this book will help you with
that
peak the new science of athletic
performance that is revolutionizing
sports by dr. mark Bub's peek is a book
I took a random chance on after loving
the cover and the title I was not
disappointed this is a true hidden gem
peak is a book that looks at the role of
nutrition sleep mood immunity focus and
more on performance it's about
optimizing the athletes health in order
to help them gain the very most out of
their bodies the book is incredibly
in-depth drawing on terms of research
and providing a lot of actionable
content I haven't seen anywhere else
some of it is really surprising such as
the argument that gee I might not
actually be a useful metric when
choosing carbs there's a little bit
dense and it can be hard to follow at
times but if you put in the work it's
more than worth it the world's fittest
book by Ross Edgar Lee Ross Edgeley is
like a far more awesome version of what
I aspire to be he's a fitness author
turned adventurer who after writing this
book went on to swim around the UK he
also has a completely unique and
scattershot approach to training which
he demonstrates in this book covering
topics ranging from work capacity to wim
HOF it's a great broad introduction
that's beautifully presented and highly
motivating I'd recommend this book to
anyone who wants to expand their Fitness
horizons and his arms are ridiculously
huge down him the best stuff is the
stuff that discusses pushing past your
limits explaining how you just need to
ignore your body's protestations that
you need to stop I love where he
explores the interplay between health
and psychology I think this is actually
going to be the focus of his next book
if I'm not mistaken Bruce Lee the art of
expressing the human body by Bruce Lee
so this book is ostensibly a guide to
Bruce Lee's fitness regime as described
by his own notes and the conclusions
drawn by editor John little while I
think that the occasional Liberty may be
taken here where premature conclusions
about Bruce's training are drawn from
little evidence there is also
undoubtedly a lot of great stuff to be
found what this really highlights is
just how experimental Bruce was
this training and the way he
incorporated concepts from bodybuilding
old-time strongman training and martial
arts into his routine was really
interesting this book is what first
introduced me to the notion of
overcoming isometrics and inspired my
own successful video on this channel now
with 2.7 million views the new
encyclopedia of modern bodybuilding by
Arnold Schwarzenegger one of my first
books on training and one of the most
influential for sure this is Arnie's
gigantic introduction to bodybuilding
which can help pretty much any newcomer
to the gym to build massive size of
course many of the strategies included
in here are now labeled as pro sciency
by some but the truth is that they work
and particularly if your primary goal is
mass this is the training method used by
the golden era bodybuilders and it
remains a fun and effective way to
workout and the book is gigantic it's
just a really good general introduction
to building muscle and how that works
we've got all the exercises listed lots
of photos of bodybuilders very inspiring
I've spoken at length about the value of
this form of training even in a
functional routine and it certainly
deserves a place in your collection the
best stuff that would definitely be the
introduction to Joe readers intensity
principles which remain among the best
ways to gain mass and experience that
feeling of pomp that Arnie raves about
this is also just one of the best ways
to develop your mind muscle connection
by the way so there you go those are my
top fitness and training books what do
you think have you read any of these
what are your favorites that I missed
I love getting your recommendations of
course many of you know that I also have
a book of my own in the works it's
called super functional training and
it's designed to be a training program
not just for building muscle but also
improving performance focus reflexes
mobility agility the longevity and more
it draws on the latest science but also
underground trading methods historical
warrior cultures martial arts and lots
more it's a book but also a full program
with a comprehensive diet plan and much
more and you can pre-order it right now
in the link in the description down
below so go and check that out for more
details if you're interested either way
thank you so much for watching this I
hope you found it useful and interesting
and stay tuned for much more like it
I've got a lot of exciting stuff on the
way thanks a ton and bye for now